có thể giác khắp mấy làm nhi cơ bảo chung bảo.
Thấy chúng ta mũ khí tượng thị văn có trà
hôm nay bà dành ngày 2018,
các bảo chà mi, tính vệt là chá mi
có vị trí tâm ở vọc hộng mươi sống phía hai độ phía bác
một chấp hàng đếp bà phía sống độ kinh đồng
trên vùng biển phía đông đạo lưu dông phía đi pình
xức sống mạnh nhất của gần tâm bảo mệ cấp chiến
bởi vì làm để tảm cái tảm khi loa vết trên dơ
sẽ cấp mấy một.
Cí chuyển theo hướng tây tây bóc
tốc độ mới làm để thay bị khi loa vết trên dơ
Cảnh bảo giễn bị bảo
từ bài 12 đến 1 chấp hai bây giờ tiếp theo
bảo xí chuyển chủ yếu theo hướng tây
mỗi dơ đi được khoảng mới làm khi loa vết
xấu có khả năng đổi hướng năng tây năng
và xí chuyển chậm lại theo bảo người đưa tin
đăng chủ ý, lę sau tên bảo xấu sấu
tính nhiều khả năng
tinh ngày môn một để hề môn năng tháng mấy bột
trên mục biển tây thay điện dơ
khu vực cần biển đông
có một át tất khách
có khả năng mận lên tánh át tất dịch đối
thẩm chỉ là bảo
sòa hướng của không khi loa
và cất đời không khi loa tăng cường
lên dễ biển cuộc gần bảo chảm y
và các bạn tiếp theo sẽ rất vụ tà